e hoje eu vou construir um aparelho que
consegue destruir qualquer iPhone
utilizando uma raquete de matar mosquito
eu vou abrir todo organismo desta
raquete juntar fio de cobre e vamos ver
a potência eletromagnética que esta para
[Música]
falar tudo pessoal daqui fala o Dark
sejam muito bem vindos a mais um vídeo e
hoje eu vou construir então um iPhone
aquilo basicamente um destruidor de
iPhones com esta raquete elétrica Ok
como é que é possível dar Vamos aprender
agora só não façam em casa né porque eu
acho que isto vai dar bosta eu vou
utilizar por um teste o meu próprio
iPhone o iPhone 12 promax portanto eu
espero que isso não funciona tão bem
como eu estou à espera Ok eu quero um
iPhone de volta mas vamos fazer o teste
também com outras coisas eletrônicas e
vamos ver o que vai acontecer
[Música]
vamos aqui só desligar lá eu sei que não
se possa se ainda não viram uma raquete
elétrica por dentro vão a primeira mão
reparem só Calma tem que abrir com muito
cuidado ok Vamos guardar estas peças
porque eu vou precisar delas mais tarde
ok Esse é o circuito isso até começou
essa madeira borda Ok a Isto é a bateria
[ __ ] pessoal Não façam isso em casa ok
Porque isso pode ser perigoso assistam
só aqui no canal Ok e agora o próximo
passo é eu vou ter que cortar um destes
cabos aqui para desligar o acesso da
bateria aqui a correto ok Porque eu não
quero levar um choque Então vamos ter
que fazer aquilo que me corte o próximo
passo que eu não vou utilizar aqui essa
parte de cima elétrica Ok portanto eu
posso literalmente
E aí
o ok então vir aqui estes cabos vamos
cortar os daqui
dessa parte eu não preciso
violência vamos agora apenas utilizar
Este mecanismo meu está ficar tão
poderoso que vai destruir qualquer
iPhone e o garante agora eu acho que
está aqui qualquer coisa mais porque eu
só preciso do Polo positivo e negativo
ou seja tenho aqui o positivo e O
negativo a de seresta aqui portanto
deste fio eu não vou precisar agora foi
desde cabo também não preciso fora agora
o que vai dar o nosso poder
eletromagnético aqui o nosso aparelho
vai ser este cabo de cobre aqueles de
eletricista mesmo basicamente o que eu
vou fazer eu vou dar aqui mais ou menos
umas cinco voltas para ficar assim desta
forma e agora vou ter que buscar aquilo
que o objetivo também e portar em ficar
mais ou menos desse tamanho
agora sim como vocês devem calcular eu
vou juntar estes dois polos no positivo
e negativo que eu vou descobrir um
iPhone a tenho certeza nem ninguém não
sei vamos fazer um pequeno teste que eu
tenho aqui outro telemóvel tenho aqui o
tomate Ah tá ok explodir o meu Android
eu não vou testar no iPhone mas vamos
ver e eu só não estou usar luvas porque
eu já te liguei aqui a bateria
lembram-se agora é só Unidos aqui os
pontos
o ok este já está agora vamos limpar
este vou só confirmar se está a passar a
corrente
Ok não está a passar a corrente não dava
choque aqui OK agora vamos precisar de
uma fita adesiva isolante Ok é muito
importante porque temos que ajudar bem
os nossos pontos de contacto Bora porque
isso não precisa de ser muito preciso Ok
eu estou a fazer isto um pouco à toa e
agora preciso ficar mais bonito eu vou
tentar aconchegar o circuito todo aqui
dentro que isso assim fica bem estável e
agora ainda vou colocar aqui mais fita
adesiva também para isso ficar bem junto
para é só pessoal como está a ficar
dando positivo e negativo juntos por
este cabo de cobre o que vai acontecer é
que aqui vai ter muita eletricidade a
circular e isto aqui ouvir mente que vai
atrofiar todos os aparelhos elétricos
onde você se aproximem a máquina vai dar
bosta eu não sei se vai dar bosta com
aparelho em si ou se com eletrônico
vamos confirmar isso mais lá para o fim
do vídeo porque porque nesta vida
construída maquineta hora vem comigo
aprenda o próximo passo vamos de é um
dos povos que neste caso é o pólo
positivo vamos Desconectar do sítio onde
ele está OK eu tenho que ficar com uma
pontinha assim fora Ok e agora o que eu
tenho que fazer é em vez de juntá-lo com
o ponto onde ele estava vamos
simplesmente colocar aqui bem perto do
ponto de forma a que todos só que passe
entre esta bolinha e o fio basicamente
vai simular um daqueles isqueiros sabem
tipo aqueles conte é mais ou menos isso
foi quem bem sim e agora já podemos
juntar então a ligação da bateria agora
sim é preciso cuidado eu vou usar aqui
umas luvas Ok só para não levar choque
pousar aqui o alicate vou tentar aqui um
um nó eu acho que já consegui né Tá mais
ou menos Ok já está junto agora vou
aproveitar para colocar mais e tem
isolante Agora sim vamos fazer o nosso
primeiro teste vamos ver se está a
funcionar como esse exposto basicamente
o que tem que acontecer tem que ocorrer
um mini só que aqui dentro Ok vamos lá
ver
estamos filha não quer levar Calma eu
acho que falei aqui e aqui neste fio o
cara tem que aproximar ainda mais
pessoal eu a pensar que estava a fazer
alguma coisa de errado porque não estava
a funcionar o meu método mas eu vim a
descobrir que o próprio a própria
raquete elétrica não estava carregada
Então o que é que nós fizemos pegamos
uma hora ela ficou carregar uma hora tá
ligado agora
olha isso agora sim
acontece o que eu queria eletrônico
queimado ok pessoal próximo passo Vamos
então se falar isto tudo porque eu não
quero levar nenhum choque elétrico
calmas o que está tudo bem Isto é que
estão aí fora o que eles não é um toque
lá olha
olha só isso tudo brincadeira agora
Agora sim está pronto o nosso aparelho
destruidor de iPhones E chegamos então
ao momento que vocês tanto querem ver
que é vamos testar esta dispositivo com
vários equipamentos eletrônicos vamos
ver o que vai acontecer inclusive eu vou
estar aqui o ecrã Com certeza que vai
dar alguma coisa que é que não seja
preciso um investimento em novos
monitores Mas enfim embora primeiro
teste vamos pegar leve Ok eu tenho aqui
uma calculadora ela acho que está a
funcionar porque eu já coloquei filha
exatamente a marca ali o zero está a
funcionar vamos ver se ela faz contas
bem um mais um é igual a dois perfeito
x65
exatamente o que eu Calculava vamos ver
então o que é que esse dispositivo faz a
calculadora Vamos colocar aqui um número
aleatório ela assim e vamos ver agora
321 vai
[Música]
a
honra de eu recebi
meu Deus se eu continuar aqui o que é
que acontece o Zé fica a pescar e
desligou agora e desligou
Não ela volta a ligar ó usar fica a
buscar oi oi ai meu Deus ver o que
aconteceu no ponto tudo
o uol uol Deus
Google calculadora toda Imagine o que
isto faz um iPhone Isto é para pagar o
iPhone todo eu
duvido que estuda o iPhone ou do gênero
mas isto vai fizer alguma coisa isso vai
afetar a memória Com certeza Bora lá
pessoal próximo dispositivo eletrônico
eu vou testar então com este relógio
reparem só ele que está a marcar as
horas houve mente que não está certo
isto se ela está tudo bugado mas vamos
ver se ele interfere com a luz se ele
interfere com as horas se ele é o reset
o relógio e vamos ver
não é feito em nada né se acender a luz
apagou Apagou a luz
com
calma eu não sei se ela dura esse tempo
o
Correio não acontece nada Este é potente
e quem não gosta eu vou então se muito
bem agora é antes do iPhone eu tenho
aqui um Android bem podre que eu já
tinha mesmo tempo aqui guardado Ok é
isso é um Alcatel não é um Android assim
nada de especial Ok Inclusive eu tenho
aqui o meu cartão SIM e não sei o pinto
é este mesmo que vai aparecer Bora três
dias não vai lá
é um burro está a piscar
eu
apago agora
eu e mais aqui embaixo
e o
vovô já foi Olha o
e
mostra o movimento Android já voltou
olha Voltou não acredito em mesmo
potente e nem tá carregado ao máximo
olha está a bugar os números estão a
aparecer aqui ó
o meu Deus ok ok quase destruiu o nosso
Android agora vamos testar pessoal eu
vou testar o meu a pelo Whats ele é bem
mais sensível vamos ver o que vai
acontecer entretanto são duas da manhã
já passou muito tempo porque eu tive que
esperar que isto carregasse esse ainda
tá dando um trabalho mas bora lá agora
eu vou ligar aqui o meu lá pelo whats e
vamos ver o que vai acontecer agora
Eu estou bem desculpa calma
é
um
deu uma piscadela
ou
olha isso não vamos desistir mas o valor
Se Aguenta muito bem agora eu estou
ansioso é pelo Iphone e se vai ter
canedos não espera antes do iPhone eu
quero ver o que é que acontece aos meus
e creches olha aproximei
em
toda a
o sistema é melhor Calma calma o relógio
biológico
se
você gostar gostar não estragou apagou
não
E aí Vem cá vem cá vem cá não acredito
que eu estraguei o Google assistente
ele só desligou não está sem imagem
G1
é ou não estragou estragou estragou
estragou Calma vou Inicial calma aí
E aí
[Música]
e você a hora
e eu acho que os treinos pixeis de um
eu
volto volta volta volta volta ou
vamos lá buscar então cor aos iPhone
pessoas que eu comento já deixa eu posso
like para lá tenho três dois um pai eo
já deu uma bugada e
eu
tocava muito choque
por isso
eu nunca vi nada assim eu nunca deste
vai acontecer nunca eu nunca visto
e eu vou manter aqui eu vou manter aqui
olha o e com ele aqui em cima não dá
mais agora agora foi agora foi ficou
tudo utilizado agora não agora foi Não
não mexe agora foi
é um e voltou oque é
que
susto hein
nós vamos resistir ver o que acontece
Olha isso tá bugado tudo
e não mexe mais eu simplesmente bloqueia
o telefone
eu bloquei ao telefone e
lhe bloqueie ao telefone mas se eu
carregar aqui acho que ele volta Olha
isso produto qualidade Ok vamos tentar
com a câmera agora outra vez
bloqueou Olha aí a lente Olha como fica
tudo personalizado Olha isso e nem dá
para mexer aqui em vídeo nem nada a
câmera funciona mas está tudo cheio de
pixeis
e isso
E aí
[Música]
e isso é surreal então pessoal devem
estar bem não quero acordar os vizinhos
porque eu estou muito impressionado eu
vou começar a gritar aqui mas enfim
vamos ficar por aqui com este vídeo
espero que vocês tenham gostado e se
quiserem que o Teste este equipamento em
outras coisas salvar uma televisão cima
Samsung enorme de 50 polegadas comentem
aí embaixo e talvez eu posso inventar
este Engenho este aparelho numa escala
ainda maior Imagina ele juntar duas três
quatro raquetes destas e construir uma
coisa ainda maior Imagine só ou não eu
vou estudar avisa para eu levar e
equipamentos para fora de longe caso
você se pode pagar metade aqui neste
vídeo já separado então Construa um
estoque não teste em casa vocês vão
avaliar se você dispositivos que não
façam aqui apenas assistam divirtam
fiquem bem até a próxima